alors faut-il aimer gagner ou détesté
perdre dit comme cela ça fait
effectivement un peu concours d'entrée à
hec
vous avez deux heures et on ramasse les
copies mais c'est rodger federer qui le
dit et lui il a choisi il le dit dans
cette passionnante et interview qu'il a
donnée au figaro il adore gagner
il le dit donc à notre journaliste
julien et ce devant et il compte bien
encore gagné le montrait à roland garros
où il revient après quatre ans d'absence
vous voyez c'est des extraits de cette
interview à l'écran marc question simple
qu'est ce qui vous fascine tant chez
rogers federer mais c'est plus grand
joueur de tennis de tous les temps
ça tout c'est comme ça c'est le meilleur
c'est la tendance de dire il est bon sur
les quatre surfaces c'est probablement
le deuxième meilleur joueur sur terre
battue s'il a été occulté son palmarès a
été occulté par rafael nadal qui
effectivement est un monstre sur cette
surface mais de celui qui arrive juste
en dessous c'est rodger federer 6 et pas
eu nadal est là certes ben il rogers
aurait gagné beaucoup plus de roland
garros que ça il a fait quatre finales à
roland garros il est passé très proche
de la victoire
plusieurs fois il a gagné en 2009 voilà
et l'homme et l'homme c'est l'homme cccc
le fair-play c'est c'est l'humidité
jamais un mot quand il perd sur le court
il ça lui arrive encore malgré son âge
avancé enfin 37 37 ans avant qu'un
relatif à 60 ans ça se voit pas je veux
dire il y perd il est dit voilà c'est
s'éteint c'est un modèle pour pour pour
l'ensemble des journalistes dont je suis
si je suis beaucoup plus âgée qui est en
tout cas pour les jeunes générations
dont mon fils et qu'il est un animal on
est maintenant parce que c'est pas sa
génération il est sur des bouclages
c'est qu'il est
les idoles voilà c'est ce qu'on lave se
convainc en cdi des leaders de demain
admirateur de réduire fédérer rien bon
je passe à neuf de joker l'homme le côté
modèles non mais ce que souligner alors
moi j'entendais ladrix il a donné cette
grande interview au figaro il a aussi il
était ce matin sur rtl jean federer il
ya deux choses qui m'ont frappée en
l'écoutant d'une part il connaît par
coeur tous ses matches depuis ce fait
combien de temps il a commencé j'entends
il ya 20 ans on a l'impression qu'ils
peuvent ou refaire les 7 et les jeux
quasiment donc ça c'est peut-être pas
très original mais ça montre quand même
c'est un état d'esprit
et puis le côté effectivement très très
plein d'humilité et modèle pour les
jeunes e-divine le dit moi je
j'ai conscience de l'importance que j'ai
dans le ce que je peux transmettre tous
très bien vous avez tous a précisé rené
ferez le code figurant au tennis je
connaissais son nom parce que
effectivement c'est un grand mais mais
que j'ai été touché comme on m'avait dit
qu'on allait on parlait cet aprem aider
donc j'ai jeté un oeil à l'interview et
effectivement j'ai trouvé ça touchant ça
doit être quelqu'un en faillite il m'est
apparu comme quelqu'un de sympathique
parce que effectivement vouloir gagner
c'est très bien il faut s'affirmer mais
il dit je ne déteste pas perdre c'est à
dire qu'en fait il mais c'est pas
seulement qu'on apprend soi mais c'est
qu'on respecte l'adversaire
si on ne déteste pas perdre c'est parce
qu'on reconnaît que l'adversaire il a
été meilleur que vous dans un cadre de
justice un pas lorsqu'on a lorsqu'il ya
eu des fraudes mais lorsque c'est clair
et juste
et bien c'est que ce gars là ils se
poussent mais pas au détriment de
l'autre il a une conscience de
l'altérité
donc c'est quelqu'un qui me semble
vraiment un humain intéressant mais sur
le plan du tennis je redescendrai celui
de la philo heureusement vous vous êtes
là alexis poulain vous avez vous
apprécié j'aime beaucoup le tennis et
roger federer aussi et c'est un des
rares sports où vous avez des sportifs
comme ça qui peut voir des carrière
aussi longue
qui peuvent s'installer comme ça dans la
la mentalité un peu de tout le monde moi
je me rappelle quand j'étais enfant
c'était mcenroe björn borg et puis en
faveur de lendl corps non mais keiko
d'or ce qui restait très tard donc c'est
rare et puis ce fair-play aussi qu'on
retrouve au tennis usta tiens encore un
peu c'est à dire que là roland garros on
a des règles on a des codes y compris
dans les gradins on doit se comporter
quand même de manière oui du département
mais les relations entre un peu en
disant on va pas se relâcher ici parce
que elle a tenu aussi des sur la tenue
aussi il y avait 2-3 de trois notes donc
c'est non parce que je pense qu'il faut
tenir cet esprit du tennis femme c'était
quoi le style oh oui
non c'est pas ça qui est l'essentiel on
et être tous internautes ils en disent
quoi il dit alors on leur demandait de
façon un petit peu comment dire
pour s'amuser faut-il aimer gagner ou
détesté perdre alors vous dites à 69%
oui donc je suppose qu'il faut plutôt
aimé gagner d'après vous que détesté
perdre nicole je le trouve très bon très
élégant sur un court et babineau nous
dit federer est très humble et très
talentueux c'est un exemple et un modèle
c'est un modèle pour la jeunesse dans le
sens où effectivement entre détester
perdre ou aimé gagner le respect de
l'autre et surtout surtout on se rend
compte que les nouvelles générations
déteste perdre et qu'en cinéaste perdre
donc vendu un peu plus philosophique
c'est le manifeste sur le court et donc
il ya une forme de nonchalance
je pense notamment un joueur australien
qui est cardio ce qui est éminemment t2
talentueux mais qui parce que il est mal
luné tel jour il va complètement lâché
un match mais avec un dédain pour
l'adversaire qui lui fait qui fait qu'il
est souvent condamnés par la justice du
tennis et ça c'est par un exemple qu'on
donne aux jeunes c'est pas un modèle
pour les jeunes
c'est le papa qui déteint sur le betis
et d'une rose parce que mcenroe mike est
exactement pareil
il ya des joueurs comme ça comerica file
et oui oui puisque c'est le show mais
l'offre est plus venue parce que il le
faisait il faisait chaud à l'époque
parce que c'était autorisé dans les
règlements ce n'est plus aujourd'hui il
se prendrait des âmes ans on a dû faire
des règlements plus sévères parce qu'il
y avait donc on l'attendait tellement
non pour la télé pour l'argent
d'ailleurs que c'est très drôle si vous
prenez une série de revers fait d'erreur
à la fin ici tu rolex 1,4 en sponsor est
le sponsor au tournoi et si vous
regardez l'interview d'rtl
il dit qu'il adore prendre peut-être
autant une petite coupette de champagne
moët aussi pour poster leur disais ce
matin conférence de rédaction que ils se
débrouillent les joueurs de tennis qui
ont justement des sponsors et des
marques pour lesquelles et qu'ils se
débrouillent pour que ce soit bien
visible sauf à l'image tout à fait
notamment notamment rogers fadeur cac
gagne est assez normal mais j'ai
vingt-trois majeurs c'est à dire de deux
grand chelem à chaque fois qu'ils
montent pour re pour mettre sa coupe
il met sa montre rolex des communes
petites que les joueurs de formule 1 il
met la casquette etc et sponsors marqué
dessus à la fin pour monter sur le
podium ça c'est je dirais c'est
consubstantiel au sport qui est devenu
maintenant qu'il n'est plus que du jeu
qui est aussi un monde d'argent
donc oui et regardez j'ai un blanc s'est
il alors de sur l'ensemble de sa
carrière c'est le deuxième qui a gagné
le plus d'argent puisqu'il a dépassé de
mémoire
je parle sous réserve plus de 115
millions de dollars de gains uniquement
gain je parle pas des contrats
publicitaires qui on dépasse largement
ses gars sportif il est simplement
dépassée par djokovic qui quelques
années - il a 6 ans - précisément il est
un petit peu plus dans le palmarès
financier et sportif
mais maintenant la grande majorité de
leurs revenus sont des revenus sportifs
et leurs carrières qui comme ça 37 ans
on l'a dit lui même
non mais il ya aussi une question de bah
oui une année de plus ces x millions en
plus bas si l'on gagne oui si on devait
renoncer nous taux des frais non mais on
se demande toujours quand arrêter
gary simplement ça dépend de sa dépend
de chacun rodger federer a la chance
d'avoir une l'intelligence du jeu il a
compris que pour pouvoir durer ce qu'il
explique dans une interview pour pouvoir
durer dans le temps
il lui fallait se ménager et avoir une
autre psychologie du jeu beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup plus jeune
il c'est pour ça qu'il ya 37 ans et il
est encore là et c'est pour ça qu'il ya
trois ans il a fait l'impasse sur roland
garros en disant comme mon objectif
c'est wimbledon je venais pas il faut
que je fasse l'impasse sur la saison de
terre battue
sinon j'y arriverai bel essai puis
épuisé à wimbledon je ne pourrai pas
gagner
donc il a l'intelligence du jeu et
aujourd'hui il est l'un de ceux qui
jouent le moins sur le circuit il a 37
ans rien de sony gagne toujours le plus
en termes de en terme de non pas de
gains financiers mais en terme de
victoires sportives c'est c'est aussi
pour ça parce qu'il met de
l'intelligence dans son jeu dans sa
stratégie dans sa planification qui est
un modèle pour les nouvelles générations
qui vont lui succéder à mon avis
incessamment sous peu
en tout cas pour vous je crois une
éventuelle reconversion aux
commentateurs
non je le saurai mais il ya des pros et
la cite à nouveau cette cette interview
à lire dans le figaro fait par jean
julien et ce vent qui dit et ça sera on
va terminer sur cette jolie note le
suisse donc il parle de federer a la
grâce du patineur de vitesse l'equilibre
du gymnaste les fulgurances de
l'escrimeur la vitesse de réaction d'un
sprinteur jaillissant des starting
blocks pour nous c'est fini ce soir
merci beaucoup à tous les quatre merci
de nous avoir suivis et évidemment
rendez vous demain pour le dernier point
de vue de la semaine
[Musique]